[Music]
thank you
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__]
[Music]
emergard
Rhonda Santos and Donald Trump are
fighting over who loves faucy the most
bouncy will you be my Valentine oh my
God it's hilarious
it's hilarious and it's fantastic can
you hear me out there I don't know if
I'm having trouble with my microphone I
can't tell yet sure no everyone is a a
confirming in the uh in the Chant oh man
it's Friday you know what Friday is bone
head of the week we got bonehead of the
week for you we also have a special
guest today on the Tony Michaels podcast
Joe flood
not all heroes wear capes but some of
them ride red bikes yes we have Joe
flood as a request from the audience
today we're very excited to have him I
did a sound in the video test with him
yesterday he is excited to be with you
and I know you have thousands and
thousands of questions for him uh and
he'll be here at the bottom of the hour
of course after the a block rant
as I give you what I think is the most
important part of the national narrative
to advance our pro-democracy Coalition
today on the Tony Michaels podcast I'm
super excited
it's May 26th we're almost to Memorial
Day weekend I guess officially we are
it's Friday right
sort of
I want to give you some news we are
going to be on Monday we will be live
here for Memorial Day I'm not gonna take
off that and we're going to do the show
we'll probably keep it to uh two hours
close
uh but we will be doing a show on Monday
and I probably will be doing the Sunday
rant
um on patreon we just might do it at a
different time this weekend I'm just
trying to figure out exactly when the
best time is going to be you know
working around barbecues and things like
that as that could go on Memorial Day
weekend
oh boy yesterday
um
so me and Gabe Sanchez were invited to a
Twitter space yesterday and it just so
happened and I wasn't able to get on and
talk I listened to some of it
um Gabe Sanchez actually went in he's
probably gonna talk about it today
um as far as getting in the space let me
tell you something
so Gabe's in the space right
he's up on stage he's not speaking yet
he's getting ready to speak I believe
um Tom Fenton was in there some other
some other [__] boxes some other Maga
[__] boxes were in this space right I
can't even believe they let us in these
spaces of the way that I talk about
these people that are in the spaces but
yeah you know
they love when we come in because we
just [__] throw Fireballs into the
space so I'm texting Gabe I'm like hey
[__] talk about covet because they're
just covered this covered that 20 20
this 20 that fouchy this fouchy that
they can't get over this stuff folks
they have [__] coveted brain I'm not
[__] you it's insanity and they're
100 focused on March April May of 2020
and what Rhonda santis did and what
Donald Trump did and who loved fauci and
who licked fauci's balls the most and
they fight over it and fight over it and
fight over it and the greatest part
about the whole thing
the greatest part about the whole
[__] thing is they tell lies and then
the other side is like no you're a liar
this is the lie that's really the truth
and the other side's like no you're a
liar this is the lie that's actually
true
we all live through it
it's not that [__] hard to understand
we were there right we watched the
stupid [__] press conferences that
the Cheeto does q and honor game we
remember when he was like yeah we should
inject bleach and then and figure out a
way to get UV light into our body and
some dumb [__]
he was talking about Iver mentoring and
height clocks of chloroquine and all
kinds of crazy ass stupid [__] at the
time we know found she was on the stage
with him we know Ronda santis was
listening to Rhonda Rhonda Santos was
listening to Anthony founti's advice
about lockdowns you people are [__]
brain dead these manga idiots are brain
dead and they're fighting over who who
hated them most who loved them the most
it's crazy ass [__] and they don't know
how they're going to get out of this
situation so Gabe Sanchez goes in
yesterday
foreign
and he's just like this is fantastic you
guys are doing a bang-up job killing
each other over something that Americans
don't give a [__] about
do you do you really think that the
American people the average working
American who's gonna go vote for
president or in any other down ballot
race is vitally concerned about who
hated fauci the most
during covet in 2020 do you think the
average American is like oh well [__]
him he loved fauci no [__] him he hated
I don't do you really think that's the
issue
they're making fools out of themselves
and we should not not stop we should let
them keep going encourage them don't
take the shovel out of their hands when
they're digging their political grade
this is fantastic
that they're fighting over this this is
the Battleground that they're gonna have
this primary on is who [__] listened
to fauci I'm not kidding you
I would I would bet I would bet that
you're gonna watch the House of
Representatives start having [__]
hearings on how Ronda Santos listened to
fauci more than Trump
I'm dead serious dead serious we're
gonna see it you're gonna have press
conferences in the house with the House
Republicans
as our [__] economy crashes because
they can't come to a deal with the debt
scene well number one they can't just
[__] pass a clean debt ceiling race
like we always have like we did three
times under Trump
but you know
That's the Way Love Goes
oh man and it is great to hear them they
[__] they just oh it's nasty they're
just you [__] you you're a liar and
you're a liar and he loved faucy no he
hated fauci vouchiness vouchy that cover
this cover that lockdown's this like
that they act like the country is still
locked down folks
I'm not sure and they act like Trump
shut down the country or Ron DeSantis
shut down Florida it's [__] it's
nuttier than [__] squirrel turds
insanity
but I'm here for it
now the funniest part is Gabe Sanchez
goes in and he he rise them you know he
he really encourages them to get into
the fight really stick the knife in and
twist it around right
and for two hours after that they talked
about it couldn't stop and then at the
end of the night I get a text message
from Gabe Sanchez he's like holy [__]
Matt gatz is in this room that's right
Matt Getz gets in the room
in the same space
and of course now he's on the Trump
train
because he knows clearly that Ron
DeSantis can't win and the reason why is
because Matt gatz knows Ron DeSantis and
that he's an awkward weird [__]
at one point he was asked he was asked
well you've done debate prep for both of
these people
if Rhonda's dentist does not have the
personality to win
Matt Getz Matt Getz
Ron DeSantis does not add the
personality to win oh my God it's
it's going to be beautiful folks this
this Republican primary is absolutely
gonna rip Maga in half
rip them in half you're gonna have
you're gonna have the people who were
encouraging the cult back Rhonda santis
and people who are in The Cult still
backing Donald Trump it's [__]
fantastic there is nothing better for
our political discourse and you know
what's you know what's crazy about this
in that room in that room they had all
the chants all the chants in the world
to talk and run their candidate whether
it be DeSantis or Trump against Biden
and they didn't do it hardly once not
once are they talking about Biden nope
NADA not happening because they got
coveted brain they have found cheap
brain they're [__] delusional these
people are outside their minds they're
way out in front of their skis they have
no clue what's gonna happen here they
are out of touch with the American
people
way out of touch with the American
people and that's why when I say look
stop talking about the Democratic
primary there's not going to be one
dummies there's an incumbent Democratic
president not only that he has a [__]
record to run on and no one wants to
challenge that record besides maybe some
dumb [__] like Marianne
Williamson who couldn't win a goddamn
primary or a delegate out of a primary
for that matter in the first place and
Robert
RFK Jr that's your answer he's a [__]
Maga he's Maga he's Maga he's not a
Democrat no [__] is gonna vote
for him maybe in an Open Primary they'll
walk across the line and try to
embarrass Biden in some of these Open
primary States but [__] that's not even
gonna do any good so get the [__] out of
here with that stuff the main key is
that they can't attack Biden on his
record they can't because average
Americans want what Biden has done
and that's why Biden did it
it's not complicated it's not hard to
understand these things inside the
discourse of our political body here
that's why I'm trying to to uh to yell
and scream the national narrative
I'm trying to tell you what kind of race
we're in and the race we're in right now
folks
the race we're in
is who love found you the most Trump or
DeSantis that's the race we're in baby
because they can't stop talking about it
and it's fantastic it is going to shake
their ship and I'm happy [__] it let's
let's throw water in their boat folks
I'm telling you if you're out there on
social media if you're out in the real
world and people are fighting about this
you be on one side and then be on the
other [__] them yeah hell yeah cause
Rhonda santis love Anthony fauci just as
much as Donald Trump did and they both
they both used him as the excuse of
their failures when they when they win
against what fauci's advice was
that's what they did
and oh my God the fact the fact that
they say that Donald Trump now is saying
uh Ron DeSantis was the biggest failure
ever he was the worst Republican
governor for covid
Donald Trump was standing out in front
of microphones going he did the best job
ever in the history of ever ever as far
as coven use it use it use it when
you're engaging with these dumb
[__] I'm telling you their
heads are going to explode
you're going to work them into a tizzy
you're going to work them into a
delusional tornado it's going to be
fantastic trust me it will work and
we're gonna keep showing you and keep
showing you and keep showing you how to
do this and they they're not going to
stop this coveted stuff
this is just not like the first
Battleground and then they're gonna move
on to something else
because the crazy part is is that Rhonda
santis and Donald Trump are talking
about the day after Stuart Rhodes who is
who is convicted of seditious conspiracy
who was just [__] sentenced to 18
years in the federal prison
they're like oh yeah hell yeah we'll
pardon the January Sixers you goddamn
right we will we'll we'll try we'll
pardon the people who tried to overthrow
the government of the United States to
put Donald Trump as dictator and King
hello they're both saying that they're
not going to be on a Battleground they
can't battle that out Rhonda santis
cannot cannot say he won't pardon these
people he won't be able to attract The
Cult
anyways he won't be able to attract a
cult
but he has to do all he can
oh it's gonna be [__] fantastic I'm
excited I'm excited for the next year
there is going to be there is going to
be huge groundbreaking political
movement in this country and what I mean
by that is people are gonna get sick and
tired of these [__] they're
gonna get sick and tired of their
discourse they're going to get sick and
tired of hearing them number one talk
about covid in March April and May of
2020 and the vaccine as if vaccine is
some sort it's 2023 it's made folks
everybody who's been vaccinated is fine
they know they're fine they were
vaccinated they're not making fake
videos on the internet where they're
shaking and [__]
they've had the vaccine they've had the
booster hell they've had covet after
they had the vaccine for crying out loud
you stupid [__]
the American people know how this works
already it's not complicated God damn
but they can't stop because they can't
be anywhere but ass deep in their lives
ass deep in their delusion of what
happened and how it happened and why why
this why this was a conspiracy why this
and they can't stop with the
conspiracies
and they can't see the forest through
the trees and we shouldn't allow them to
[__] them [__] em [__] em [__] em let
them keep stepping on rakes let them
keep face planting again do not take the
shovel out of their hands when they're
digging their political grave because
I'll tell you that I'll tell you
something that I know
the American people don't give two shits
about who Anthony Fout she is and who
loved Anthony fauci more and who locked
down what and who didn't lock down this
that's all over [__] that's all
done
we're past that what are you gonna do
for us and if they keep talking about
the past the 2020 election the January
6th Insurrection and March April and May
of 2020 they are going to lose big time
in the general election they don't have
a chance in [__] hell the only thing
that we have to do with the national
narrative is we have to draw the down
ballot races into these fights
we have to draw these Republican primary
down ballot races into these fights
because the American people will finally
see the Republican party for who they
are the real America First nincompoop
Nazis who were delusional who are who
are Tethered to delusion no reality
whatsoever we are at the intersection of
WrestleMania in real life and the Maga
store is on one corner and the GAC store
is on the other
that's right gack
that's Ron DeSantis Great American
comeback gak Maga and gack
that's it are you [__] kidding me
all right
that's it you couldn't sum it up any
better you couldn't sum it up any better
than manga and Geck
ooh baby I'm excited I'm super excited
about the fight between Ron DeSantis
and Donald Trump apparently there was
some um news uh with Donald Trump I
totally missed it because I I couldn't
help but the uh to see the [__] ass
[__] cat fight
going on between him and his supporters
now you may say you may say something
like well Tony I mean
you're just in these Twitter spaces and
these Twitter spaces are aren't really
aren't really where it's going to happen
[__] I don't know if you know who
the people are in these Twitter spaces
but I'm telling you these people in the
Twitter spaces are the ones who are
trying to [__] push The Narrative of
the Republican Party they're trying to
push The Narrative of this primary and
they're trying to set the stage for the
Battleground that they want to have
happen
how do you think this works see this is
the one thing that Democrats and
liberals always always discount they
always discount the ability of people to
set their their narrative
and for Talking Heads to absolutely
drive it they always they always did
liberals and and and and and and the
left always think that the mainstream
media drives this [__] they do not have
to drive the messaging that is not true
at all we have way more power than what
we've ever had in the history of this
country and the history of politics we
have we have way more power now
I mean to to be frank to yesterday's
point when we were talking about Twitter
and Twitter spaces about the mainstream
media of course the mainstream media has
less influence now than maybe they had
10 years ago
on the driving of the messaging in the
narrative
but it doesn't mean that they don't
understand the media
but we have full control and until we
actually realize that because that's
where the left and liberals and
Democrats in general have failed over
the last 30 40 years
is they react to the National narrative
they React to what what the Republicans
are doing [__] that we set the narrative
we drive the political messaging that's
what we can do as the pro-democracy
Coalition we can do that
and one of the ways we do that is
absolutely 100 [__] mock this [__]
out of manga and Gak
and the manga gak war is going to be
where we win this fight of democracy
because we are going to make absolute
fools out of them
the American P I'm telling you I'm
telling you when the American people
find out
that Donald Trump and Ronda santis are
fighting over who loved fauci more
they're gonna be like what the [__] what
why are they arguing over that
like I I want you to tell me about what
you're gonna do so I don't go broke
because of a medical bill I want you to
tell me what the [__] you're gonna do
about my retirement
Medicare Social Security I want you to
tell me what the [__] you're gonna do
about making sure my children start
schooling three instead of five and that
they eat lunch every day and that we
actually have public schools I wanna I
wanna hear something about that
how about what you're gonna do with
roads and bridges and infrastructure in
this country how about that
hmm
how about that how about how about what
you're gonna do for the American people
nope all they're gonna do is fight over
I won in 2020 their election was rigged
I liked I like fauci less than him fauci
didn't tell me what to do he told him
what to do
I wanna I wanna pardon the January 6
political prisoners that that were
involved in violent Insurrection to
overturn the government to make Donald
Trump the king of the castle
that's where listen to me what I'm
telling you
that is what their message is
folks and then you added Ronda Santa's
war on wokeism
oh [__] as if the American people give
two shits about what their neighbors
who they want to marry and who they want
to love get the [__] out of here with
that nonsense as long as you're not
telling them what to do you you can't
tell other people what to do
this is this is all weird ridiculous
stuff folks but it is the time that we
live in and boy what a time to be alive
it's a q Anon World folks we're just
living in it
oh I am really excited I'm telling you
you should be excited too
a lot of people are really um just in a
fervor this morning and pissed off and
they're they're really upset the
mainstream media is exceptionally upset
that Rhonda santis and Donald Trump are
talking about pardoning the January 6
insurrectionist
on the heels of of Stuart Rhodes being
sentenced to 18 years in prison for uh
his his conviction of seditious
conspiracy
I'm excited about that I'm not [__]
upset we we should be surprised that
these treasonous [__] like
Republicans want to Pardon a bunch of
bunch of treasonous pieces of [__] that
would support overturning the government
for them we're supposed to be surprised
[__] out of here with that nonsense stop
acting so surprised stop acting so mad
that that's their stance you knew that
would be their stance they're vile
pieces of Nazi [__]
let's defeat them let's [__] defeat
them and not just at the top of the bow
let's work our ass all the way down the
ballot let's defeat them everywhere
not just on not just in the House of
Representatives in the Senate but in
these state legislators too and these
Governor races let's defeat these
[__] these treasonous pieces of
real America First Nazi bastards that's
what we should do
being mad because their stance is to
their stance is to pardon the people who
would overturn the government in their
name [__] out of here come on we know
that that's their stance we know that
that's what they want of course that's
why that's why you see Charlie Kirk
wanting to defund the FBI is because
turning points USA is probably under
investigation in the FBI for January 6.
why do you think Matt Gantz and Marjorie
Taylor Greene and Lauren Bowe Donald
Trump all want the [__] FBI gone so
they're not investigated why do you
think Republicans want to get rid of the
FBI is because the FBI is a threat to
them and their freedom because they're
criminals
[__] out of here of course of course
of course
they're going to have The Stance that
they should pardon the criminals that
would make them the king criminals
and I I'm supposed to be surprised [__]
out of here
you want to have outrage you direct
outrage and you do it correctly you do
it loudly and you do it proudly
speaking of that I have a great guest
today oh my gosh and he he didn't even
know he I I talked to Joe yesterday he
didn't even know he's being recorded
when this happened we showed this video
and I'm gonna replay the video and we're
gonna have plenty of questions for Joe
and I hope he has plenty of time to join
us today
um we're gonna go to break here and
bring Joe back but
I'm telling you not all heroes wear
capes but sometimes they ride red bikes
and he didn't even know he's being
recorded that day and he is a hero
because he was loud he was proud he knew
to disrupt them even if he even if he
didn't know he's being recorded his job
was to was to
interrupt and disrupt the nincompoop
Nazis that's the point that's the whole
point that's the point of this show to
be quite Frank and that's what we're
going to continue to do every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific it's Friday
Friday Friday you know what that means
bone head of the week at the top of the
hour don't forget to subscribe here on
the Tony Michaels podcast on YouTube
you're not going to want to miss a
single episode also follow us on Twitter
that's how you vote for bonehead of the
week on Twitter at Tony Michaels pod and
on the community tab on YouTube you vote
you decide who is the bonehead of the
week and we break it down for you in the
second hour me and my co-host Gabe
Sanchez also download every single
episode on Apple Spotify and Google it's
free 99 over there I know I was a little
late yesterday getting it up I had a
little bit of trouble I'm running out of
storage space we're at episode 400 and I
don't know some thousand I don't know
I'm just kidding it's like 404. it's a
lot of damn episodes two hours of so I
got to do the Audio I gotta do the video
I'm running out of space
so I gotta find some storage space to
have all this stuff oh boy so I was late
getting it up yesterday so I apologize
but it yesterday's episode is up it is
running it is going today's will be the
same way oh by the way you can watch
this also live on Facebook if you still
have Facebook you can go at the Tony
Michaels at the Tony Michaels you can
watch us live on Facebook and I want to
thank everyone over on Twitch I know
that I do I've been doing this every day
but it's been growing and growing and
growing over on Twitch we're so close
listen to this I'm just looking at it
now we're so close to 1200 followers on
Twitch and I know that doesn't seem like
a lot but it's a big deal just in the
last few weeks we're
1197 followers it's free to follow us on
Twitch you don't have to spend a single
nickel all you got to do is open up
account over on Twitch and give us a
follow over there go to twitch.tv
Michaels that's twitch.tv just go to our
page the Tony Michaels if you have an
Amazon Prime account listen I can do one
better
if you have an Amazon Prime account
you get one free subscription
because on on Twitch the follow is free
but the subscription cost money
it's weird because it's the opposite on
YouTube anyways
the subscription if you have Amazon
Prime you get one free subscription on
Twitch with your Amazon gaming account
if you link your Amazon account and your
Twitch account you can give us that one
free subscription and we get some money
each month and it doesn't cost you a
single nickel so go do that if you can
go to the Tony michaels.com that's the
Tony michaels.com the link is just the
fourth one down it says link Amazon and
twitch it gives you the exact directions
to do that and we appreciate all the
support that you guys give us um rather
it's through patreon through twitch here
on YouTube on Facebook on Twitter
sharing the link every single day
getting the message out there getting
more and more people involved in this
audience I am super excited because
you're the best audience in the world
and we got a great guest today holy moly
You're Gonna Love Him you've been you've
been you've been at calling for me to
have him
on the show today so Joe flood's going
to join us right after this break don't
go anywhere Joe flood right after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
White was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we got plenty of Slam gems skull
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again
here's Bob
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag now they lived love and blue one
in your absence I discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day years Tammy
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the show as I
said earlier not all heroes wear tapes
sometimes in Washington DC when a bunch
of Nazis go to quote unquote protest
they show up in a red on a red bike and
they yell and scream and they get loud
because that really truly is the fascist
Kryptonite loud noises they are
terrified of them rather it's a whistle
or it's Joe flood Joe flood welcome to
the Tony Michaels podcast how are you my
friend
nice to be here yeah I'm so glad to have
you now here's the thing and a lot of
people have been following you here
since since the event happened because
you didn't know you were being recorded
right is that am I correct in that yeah
I assume the camera was on the Patriot
front not me right right but you were
you were just riding by so tell us tell
us what actually happened because we see
that little clip and we see you standing
there with your bike and yelling at them
and mocking them appropriately by the
way very very good at the mocking by the
way but tell us how it transpired when
you when you got there did you notice
them did you hear that they were going
to be there so you drove you rode your
bike down there tell us about that yeah
it was kind of rainy that day and so I
just went out to get some coffee and um
I uh was getting coffee and they I saw
on Twitter that the Patriots front had
snuck into town and were marching on the
National Mall and they had done this a
couple times before they'll sneak into
DC March around like the Lincoln
Memorial and get photos and then leave
before anybody has a chance to confront
them so they're getting like a free
photo op without any opposition and so I
saw on Twitter that they were on the
mall and I was like less than a mile
away at a coffee shop and I thought well
I can go intercept them and
um there was a capital Bike Share
station across the street so that's the
red biker Road it's a capital Bike Share
which is like right Bike Share system so
this is the deal where you have an app
and and and it's kind of like public so
you can rent the bike and use that bike
to go down to a mile down the road to to
uh you know yelling agreement Nazis is
it is that kind of what we're talking
about here yeah I use the bikes all the
time there's stations all over the place
right right great
and so um yeah I hop on the bike and
like I wasn't sure where they were
exactly so I figured I'll go I'll start
at the Washington Monument so I went
down there and they just happened to be
there and oh okay when I rolled up
um I saw like cop cars on the grass
around the Washington Monument and then
there was a line of bike cops and then
there was the patriot front all on the
line as their leader was giving a speech
they're all like in parade formation and
no one seemed to see me coming like all
the bike cops were looking at the
Patriot front and the Patriot front were
looking forward and so nobody seemed to
see me coming up from
um their left hand side so that's why I
was able to just like roll in and start
calling them losers and saying that
their mom hates Summit and so it was
perfect it was perfect and we might um
we might be a get get time to play the
video but I have so many questions so
when you got there was there any other
opposition or was you pretty much the
only one that was there to to
intentionally oppose them was there any
other opposition in there
I expected counter protesters to be
there but I think that they've snuck
into town there were no real counter
protesters so they were like most of the
tourists were staying away from all of
this mess because they just saw this
group with upside down flags and then
surrounded by police officers so all the
tourists were staying away there were a
couple other people there present who
were also sort of sort of off and on
yelling at them as well uh calling them
like blank and crackers and uh you know
things like that so I wasn't going well
you can use you can use any words you
want on this okay we're we're not all
I'm like [__] crackers there you go
we're not we're not scared of curse
words on this yeah that's the beauty
that's the beauty of the internet and
the beauty of the Tony Michaels podcast
is we're definitely not scared of the
word [__] so so you get there now my
question is the police officers you said
there was a lot of police officers there
a lot of them seem to be on bikes at
least in the video that that you were in
um did it seem like they were protecting
Patriot fronts or they were really just
making sure they didn't get out of hand
or what what was law enforcement's job
on the scene that you saw when you were
witnessing it well so obviously the
Patriot front must have talked to police
before they came to town because there
was like 50 bike cops surrounding them
so there was some sort of coordination
between the Patriot front and and the
police
maybe for their protection or for DC's
protection I don't really know but yeah
they're surrounded by by cops
I got you I got you so how long were you
actually there I'm gonna bring in Gabe
Sanchez he's he's joined us here how
long were you actually there like on the
scene this is Gabe Sanchez this is the
co-host by the way I know you guys yeah
hi hi how you doing thank you thank you
for your work oh my pleasure yeah we
always we always like the the loud noise
kryptonites for the fascists in this
country it's always a great thing so so
what was how long did this last like how
long it and did you scare them away like
when you started yelling we're like oh
no we got it and they spread like
cockroaches or what what was it like
after the video because we see the video
where you're you're mocking you pull up
a good version of that while we're
sitting here talking
yeah I was there it was 15 minutes this
guy was given the speech and he kept
having to pull out his speech because he
couldn't remember it which I thought was
ridiculous I mean this is your big event
you can't remember your speech that was
I think the thing which offended me most
of all weirdly enough was like it was
just so unprofessional because he had
kept having to pull out his speech and
I'm like why can't you memorize your
speech and um
yeah and that well you know you know
that's funny that you mentioned that
because you're you're very you're very
familiar with DC right because you're a
photographer there in DC
um you you live there it it's your home
it's your home and so you're very
familiar not just with like the
different areas but you're also familiar
with when people have protest I mean you
you experience a lot of protests because
you are right there in DC
yeah and I think that really helped me
because I knew the rules basically of
protests in DC
um that you know the police were there
to sort of basically the police just
want to keep everybody separate that's
their mission is to keep protesters and
counter protesters separate they don't
want people mixing it up in the middle
of the street and fighting and so I knew
that as long as I stayed on the other
side of the police line I could say
whatever I want and that's sort of like
the Patriots front was in a public space
I'm in a public space we can both say we
both have free speech rights to say
whatever we want and DC is really good
about that
um and respecting that because they're
used to that protest and and Robbie
brings up a good question here on
YouTube speaking towards this angle here
he says is Patriot fund getting protest
permits so did they have a permit to be
there that day or or do you know did you
did you check on this afterwards or what
what what was the actual organization of
patriot fronts surprising DC with their
with their little parade as you called
it
yeah I don't know
um I don't know I don't like my
understanding of the rules in DC is that
you don't need a a permit to protest
like the DC police like you to have a
permit but you don't necessarily need to
have one because there's lots of sort of
protests which are sort of spring up in
the street and March around in DC please
sort of
you know it's not like other places like
Florida where they would just beat the
hell out of you I mean DC police sort of
tries to keep everybody safe and will
block off the street even if you don't
have a permit for a protest right if one
just kind of Springs up we've seen this
before we're not really yet exactly
protests but even uh big celebrations
um one of the ones that we've witnessed
before that um was it was
um kind of inspiring to our country was
when Barack Obama came out late one
night and announced that Osama Bin Laden
had been killed
um and that they captured him and and um
and and this big huge mass of people
um just kind of converged on DC and
around the White House and it was one of
the most spontaneous things in the
middle of night that I've ever seen um
of course you've probably experienced
this before but
um but tell us about DC in general
because I think I think people are
interested in that because uh Margie
brings up a good point she said she's
almost finished with your book and I
want you to plug your book and your
stuff later but but tell us us about
your experience in DC and how how
trumpism and and Maga has kind of
changed this because I assume that you
were there in the city the day of
January 6
um and the aftermath of January 6th so
tell us about how all that's changed
since you know DC so well yeah I'm a
writer and a street photographer so I've
photographed lots of protests and yes
the Trump era was terrible and
especially the year 2020 was
particularly off all in DC and that
whole lead up to January 6th was in like
November December 2020 was awful
um where you had two big rallies
um pro-trump rallies in November and
December of 2020 where basically Trump
forces were allowed to do whatever they
want
um they you know proud boys marched
around the street they beat people up
who they thought were antifa just random
people
um they uh you know vandalized churches
I mean they basically just ran riots and
there wasn't really any counter protests
um
to them and like I actually witnessed
that too and like being like I think
part of this is that is like white
privilege on my part as a white male
like you know they're not really they're
not going to hassle me but like I
witnessed the proud boys threatening
like like literally like kids who were
carrying like a black lives matter flag
on black lives matter Plaza I mean these
are like full ass
grown man like five or six of them eight
a.m on a Sunday morning threatening a
couple of kids in the black lives matter
flag I mean they're just thugs uh just
on just absolute Thugs and um yeah after
witnessing that in November and December
and then on January 6th like all of
those Trump people were staying in
hotels in my neighborhood and so I saw
them I saw that mob March up to the
Capitol and I saw they were armed they
were all they came to fight they had on
uh helmets body armor camouflage they
were carrying weapons they were carrying
baseball bats hockey sticks batons
pepper spray I mean they came to fight
there's like when people say that ah you
know that it was a peaceful protest like
no they came to fight and like I saw the
March up at the Capitol and the mayor
told everybody to stay inside that day
because people knew something terrible
was going to happen like we didn't DC we
didn't really know what was gonna happen
but the mayor told everybody to stay
inside that day because everybody knew
something awful was going to happen and
so I watched them March up to the
Capitol and then I saw them come back
that evening where they all celebrated
back in their hotels and it was like the
most and that just was the most
disgusting thing I'd ever witnessed
um ever to see them celebrate even the
next day when they left town they're all
waving their Trump Flags around like
they've done something great and
witnessing that just made me enraged
that they could just get away with that
that
um and since then that's why I think I
became
you know less of a bystander and more of
somebody who would go out in and protest
well we we really do appreciate it let's
let's show the video here
um of you not not putting up with being
a bystander anymore but getting in the
fight
um let's see if I can get this clip here
this is this is one um
let's see this is this is one version of
the video there's several versions of
the video of you of you doing this again
you're not aware you're not aware of
people videotaping at this point you're
just going down to be the loud uh loud
Kryptonite of the fascist yeah
foreign
[Music]
okay okay I have to I have to say Joe
that the reclaim your virginity really
got me I think that's actually when I
found this video I'm like oh that's the
one that's how I retweeted was your
quote reclaim your virginity because I
think that really describes Patriot
front more than anything because their
their slogan of course they had a big
banner you can see there's called re
reclaim America because it's about white
supremacy right it's about this great
replacement stuff but Gabe you've done
videos and Gabe he's done videos of
patriot front about U-Haul mocking them
uh the last time they were in DC
um he has a video where he puts uh
underwear Whitey tighties on his face
because it just looks and he posted that
video uh when when Patriot front was in
and your video in the video of you was
trending and boy I tell you
um Gabe Sanchez and you are like allies
here because patreon front hates you
almost equally at this point so Gabe do
you have any questions for Joe
yeah so actually there's a it seems like
there's a question from the chat have
you faced any uh backlash uh now that
you now that you've been kind of
um presented before everyone to say
that's the guy that was on the red bike
he's the one that spoke out against
these fascists like have you received
any sort of backlash obviously you've
received a lot of positive
um thanks and attribution but is there
anyone on the opposite end
no I mean there's like a few just sort
of snarky comments but um the only yeah
I haven't received any backlash I mean
people you know online were saying oh
the patreon are feds I mean that was
sort of the oh yeah I love that one yeah
that one's great yeah that was sort of
the I think that's what they're going at
going forward the right way yeah they
seem to be it it's it seems even from
2021 I want to say they've had this you
know idea that their feds they're the
FBI you know even when the videos of
their you know when they were doing Nazi
salutes and and doing their weird erotic
strip search things you know they're
like these are the feds and it's like
yeah I'm sorry that you don't like the
fact that you're being made fun of right
now well you know that that's a good
point and and you've been around a lot
of feds because you're in DC where it's
just like the home of the feds right so
tell us
explain to the audience why Patriot
fronts and why these Nazi movements are
not feds they're not feds they're actual
Nazis or neo-nazis these are fascists
these these people are are at the you
know in just entrenched in white
supremacy that's what they want to get
our nation back to it's not some psyop
it's not some false flag it is truly
fascist these aren't feds I mean they
could be like cops and firefighters
somewhere you know I mean I know that's
true right the DC Lieutenant right that
he was just indicted right for exactly
helping give Intel to the Patriot boys
right the proud boys well it is
confusing right Patriot front proud boys
but tell us tell us Joe how you know
that that Patriot front and some of
these other groups aren't they're not
feds it's not some psyop this isn't some
weird conspiracy tell us how you know
that because of your experience in DC
uh because if they were feds I think
they would be better organized and
better you know because like when I got
up like I think this and there's a
difference between seeing photos or
something and being up close and
personal like in photos they kind of
look like a military unit but if you see
them up close and personal you notice
the flaws that they were all wearing
different color pants like you know
they're supposed to be in uniform but
they're all wearing different kind of
khakis different
different types of brown and tan and and
so it didn't they weren't uniform and
wearing different types of
boots and shoes and so on and um and the
way they marched they were not marching
in I mean they're marching
they weren't really like a military
group I mean especially if you
contrasted them versus the the police
who surrounded them who were like the
real deal I mean the police were you
know in all in their professional
uniforms and they're obviously worked
together as a team and they knew what
they're doing they weren't like these
guys and they were carrying plastic
Shields too the Patriot front people
like these plastic like Fisher-Price
Shields which just looked ridiculous so
that's why I said they were sloppy
because they didn't impress me as as a
military or paramilitary group they
impressed me as like a bunch of random
dudes who yeah had been strip searching
each other out in the woods and then
came to DC to March around yeah so I
mean they really they there is there's a
near where I live on the weekends like
every other weekend or so there's a
bunch of people who do uh Who cosplay
and they go out and they do sword
training and things like that right yeah
they perform and there's a lot and like
I have more respect for those guys who
do it as a hobby than these guys who try
to go out there and be like we're you
know were these guys who are going to
reclaim America and it's like what are
you reclaiming you're trying to reclaim
the whiteness in this country you're
you're uh triggered and upset that
there's uh you know a person of color or
a woman or someone from a marginalized
Community getting a voice and a say but
yeah I have more respect for the guys
that are at the park that are LARPing
yeah along for the ride here on on
YouTube LARPing so uh I have more
respect for those people during the
weekends than I do for these guys who
you've pointed out who are not
coordinated who are you know probably
just borrowing items from their parents
house you know like I'm I made a joke in
a video that The Shield was really just
like the the glass cover on a on a pot
right like that's it they're just
pulling random things to be like yeah
I'm I'm military I'm I'm I'm I'm a tough
guy you know and really it's they're
just a bunch of weaklings well it's kind
of like when you were a kid you took
your mom like a bath towel and you you
you tying around your mom would tie it
around your neck and you were a
superhero right or and you know just
just different things around the house
you tried to make yourself feel like a
superhero which makes me think of this
but you know it makes me think the
contrast because earlier you were
talking about like the upkeepers and the
proud boys
um coming and protesting in DC and it
seems like the proud boys way more
organized uh way more paramilitary way
more uh entrenched and in different
tactics
um than this group here this group does
seem like a Fisher Price type uh joke
right where so contrast because you've
seen the proud boys obviously you've
seen the Patriot front so give us give
us your take give us your um your
comparison of the two what would you say
sets these different groups apart seeing
that that The Oath Keepers and the proud
boys have now been convicted of
seditious conspiracy and we see that
Stewart Rhodes yesterday the founder of
The Oath Keepers which by the way and
for the audience we have interviewed his
ex-wife now ex-wife uh Tasha Adams and
his son Dakota Adams so if you want to
watch that interview you go to the
YouTube channel subscribe but there's
the playlist there for The Oath Keepers
and the proud boys and all the
interviews we've done with Dakota and
Tasha are there but he was convicted or
he was a sentence yesterday to 18 years
in prison by a federal judge in D.C for
seditious conspiracy for trying to
overthrow the government in the United
States so tell us the contrast between
what you saw on January 6th and some of
those some of those marches before
January 6 and then these goofball these
Fisher-Price goofballs the Fisher Price
fascist I like that better the
Fisher-Price bashes that you saw
um just a couple weeks ago in DC when
they were trying to reclaim their
virginity oh excuse me reclaim America
tell us the difference between the two
yeah I mean when the um yeah the
priorities that I saw in November and
December of 2020 came to fight they were
big grown men they weren't like 19 year
old Guys these were like older bigger
like sort of Roid Rage kind of dudes and
they were wearing like you know tactical
gloves to punch people and had backpacks
full of
equipment like you know pepper spray and
things probably more weapons than that
as well and they traveled in packs and
they looked
to fight they were looking to people to
provoke and to fight and then like gang
up on them like five or six guys on one
and that's what I saw I saw them trying
to pick fights with people and you know
and it would be like five or six guys
against one or two you know kid who they
thought was antifa
um and then on January 6th I saw people
who I think were Oath Keepers
um who to me looked like the National
Guard they're all in camo gear and they
had on patches and they had on body
armor and they had helmets on I'm like
how do you tell
the National Guard from these guys
because they're they look exactly the
same uh and I remember in the morning
January 16th seen them marching down the
street and and I was very worried
because uh if these people are
pretending to be military I mean how we
we as Citizens wants to know the
difference between the military and the
goalkeepers because they all look the
same they're all the same gear so that's
the difference I think and then you had
the Fisher Price fascist as as we have
coined the phrase now thank you so much
for that that we've gotten to that name
um Joe I I know we're running out of
time here with you and I appreciate you
coming you must come back if you ever
see something in Washington and you want
to talk about it feel free come on the
show um I know the audience will have
plenty of questions about these things
if they trend on Twitter if there's a
protest whether it's good or bad whether
it be a protest of a bunch of
Fisher-Price fascists are a protest
against those Fisher-Price fascists
please come back on the show but tell us
about your book tell us where people can
find you give us a a Shameless plug if
you will yeah I I have a website Joe
flood.com where I blog and share my and
so on and then I recently set up a
website with a couple friends of mine
called
redbikeguy.com and so you can buy
T-shirts which say cargo pants are out
yeah that's great that's great so go
follow Joe on Twitter it's at Joe flood
that's at Joe flood and go to his
website Joe flood.com uh go go support
Joe and Joe I hope you come back and and
anytime you see something that you you
would like to share with us and our
audience uh feel free to send it to me
we'll get you on the show uh we love
having you here on the show I know the
audience has been wanting to have you
since we played the original video uh
where you were heckling the Fisher Price
fascist there in DC Joe you're you are a
hero my friend you are a hero keep it up
keep being loud because they do not like
loud noises thank you my friend for
joining us all right well thank you
everyone stick around we'll be right
back with bonehead of the week right
after this break
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment [__]
um we're
[Music]
to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show I'm so excited
he's ninjas
to make the phrase and coin the phrase
Fisher-Price fascist with the help of
Joe flood oh my God that's getting
better than that on a Friday
we got bone of the week coming up we got
boneheads you know what I was thinking
about something during the commercial
break maybe maybe Joe should use a
phrase or have like a tagline you know
like we should flood
I don't know flood these fascists with
you know or like flood out yeah
right you know that's not bad that's not
bad that's not a bad uh you know if it's
like flood these fascists or it's like
flood these fascists out or something
like I feel like there's there's
something here with the word flood and
you know pushing pushing the Bat Out you
know because you got flood fascists they
won't start with f you know that's how
I'm like that's why I like the Fisher
Price fascist because right you know it
works in there I don't know I think
that's great again maybe flood maybe
flood out fascism
flood out fascism right I don't know
maybe maybe we'll shoot it to him in a
DM to see if we can get that going oh
man we got a bunch of boneheads this
week I hadn't I I'm I want to be
completely clear about this Gabe Sanchez
did this entire poll all by he didn't
even consult me last dude I was you were
like
I was I was at assault you know what
it's like I gotta I got I gotta I gotta
excuse me guys my back hurts because I'm
carrying the show right now oh my god
listen to this guy listen to this guy he
puts out one damn pole without saying
anything to me and all of a sudden and
all of a sudden no he did he put out the
pole
um and he gave us there were many there
were many things there were many late
last minute contenders that I'm like oh
God not enough you weren't talked about
enough or like uh compared to this
person not enough of Bonet still a
bonehead right not enough of a bonehead
and then we have a special appearances
in the alpha [__] and the dishonorable
mention so we'll get to those so let's
do it let's just let's just start
bonehead of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
it's Friday it's Memorial Day weekend
and this is bonehead of the week and boy
do we have boneheads it really honestly
these three boneheads that are on the
bonehead pole all kind of it it's all
kind of one thing right it's like it's
all related one big huge pile of trash
um you'll know what I'm talking about
here we're Governor Ron weirdo DeSantis
meatball pudding fingers Ron Elon Musk
and the Cheeto does q and honor himself
Grandpa goopy pants Donald Trump each
one of these uh gentlemen if you want to
give them that title
have appeared on bone end of the week
before
um this is not their first appearance
but
it is getting to be a little weird
situation why they're appearing on
bonehead of the week so who shall we
start with first should we start with
Elon should we just go there first yeah
we'll probably go with you why not why
not what could it possibly be that Elon
uh did this week
that prompted his appearance on the on
the bonehead of the week pole it's it's
almost like there was a yeah
uh that yeah how do I put this uh
uh a failure of a presidential launch
that he was co-sponsoring I got it I got
it uh there was something else in the
back of my mind this morning where I was
like oh Elon also did that [__] too
yeah man I'm blanking out but basically
we'll start with that one if I remember
what the other one is then I'll go with
it but you know a lot of people are are
uh knocking Elon for the Cyber truck the
Tesla cyber truck I didn't see that no
no no yeah but I did I did read about
how oh you know what actually I remember
it was connected with the with the
Twitter space it was the fact that Elon
report from from people within Twitter
they said Elon was [__] livid about
the performance of the Twitter space
even though he and David sacks after you
know on in public spaces were like oh it
was great oh people probably went by and
said who was he mad at who it is still
working at Twitter that he could
possibly be mad at well I don't know
there was a recent uh high level I don't
know if it was an exact but a high level
person at Twitter recently quit so oh
really wow oh man yeah who could see
that coming how long do you think the
CEO is Gonna Last this new CEO a week or
two what do you think buy Into Summer uh
she'll be gone
how long how long do you think this will
give it you know what I'll give it I'll
give her the benefit of the doubt I'll
say till the end of the year oh okay 31.
23. okay I'll say you know what we'll
we'll wrap up we'll get at least six
months in you'll have till the end of
the year and then she'll be like you
know what it's not what I thought so I'm
gonna make it I could be wrong but I'll
say this uh May 26th 1002 Pacific Time
by by December 31st 2023 at 11 59 59
she'll be gone wow okay you know what it
would be funny if it was like New Year's
Eve Elon sneaks in
cuts her off she's no longer the CEO
when you wake up I'm just like because
at the end of the day like and Gabe
Sanchez is like the the predictor of all
predictors
over here the soothsayer chips and
Giggles chips and Giggles that's what
they call me Noster gabis
but honestly like the idea that she's I
don't even know I haven't heard anything
about what she's done wait I I mean is
she officially the CEO now I mean I
don't like it I honestly don't know
there was all this like hey charge over
there when did she take it when right
because new Twitter CEO well it's funny
because he tried to extend an olive
branch by about six weeks okay so she's
not the CEO yet she in about six weeks
after so do you think do you think it
within six I I actually predict within
six weeks maybe she'll be like nah no
thanks no it's quite possible she could
be like no I'm not gonna I'm good which
is funny because you you saw I'll go on
unemployment
she's like can I still get unemployment
if I right can I take the job yeah right
but but the idea that when the news came
out you know it was Elon Musk before
that was like oh mainstream media is
just a big propagandist machine that's
pushing you know woke ideologies and
then was like hey you know what guys I'm
gonna hire someone that's from the
mainstream media and then all the people
online you had like Ian miles strong was
like no guys guys guys guys she's not a
leftist like everyone Ian miles do you
mean turbo fem I mean turbo fem for
those who don't know email strong you
might know him as turbo them if you
that's how you hear that the guy that
literally lives in Malaysia but wants to
talk about how women should not have
rights you know bodily autonomy uh they
should not have uh say in terms of their
their medical kind of uh right they that
we should vote for DeSantis the guy it's
really weird man the guy has no stakes
in the U.S political game I wonder what
it could be it's almost like it's almost
like he's some sort of paid political
operative it's crazy it's it's almost
yeah it's almost like maybe maybe that
he's maybe he's getting paid by someone
else right maybe it's a [__]
it could be DeSantis it could be
Christina Pusha it could be whoever
right like
oh man let me tell you something when
you bring up the santis and push all oh
my God it's so [__] delicious to
watch these people fight each other's
talking about it in the a block today
about this Twitter space you were in and
since we're on Elon and Trump and
DeSantis which it's like all roads lead
to [__] coveted brain with these
boneheads they could not stop talking
about it yeah I mean I mean I'm sure
people uh people who follow me uh on
Twitter saw that I was in the Twitter
space last night I spoke in the Twitter
space yeah yeah I was in the Twitter
space I was on stage I was talking and
at like four I want to see it was like
four some 4 30 something something like
that I was like they were like Gabe what
do you think as a liberal like what
what's your like take on this whole
thing and I was like don't stop talking
about this this is great I was like you
guys can't you cannot stop attacking
each other and here's like even if I
point it out like I'm just doing it
right now I was like look you guys
cannot stop talking about covid you
can't stop talking it was like there's a
video of of uh of Donald Trump attacking
Ron DeSantis for not knowing how to
handle covet you got clips of a
compilation of of Donald Trump praising
did you post that on your profile no I
didn't post that on the game uh but
maybe if I can find it real quick then
you've got uh then you've got a
compilation like of of 18 to 20
different instances of Donald Trump
praising
the governor of Florida Ron DeSantis for
the way that he handled covid and then
on on separately you've got Ron DeSantis
you know doing a publicity moment to say
hey I trust the vaccine and this
hundred-year-old veteran is gonna get is
the millionth vaccine in Florida and
they they put it on uh they
um
uh they put it on on Fox News it was
like Fox and Friends I think and then
you've got you know Donald Trump who
also got the vaccine right but now
they're you know there's like oh it's
for the states to decide oh it's for the
government oh I'm I'm anti-fouchy I'm
Pro fauci I'm anti-vaccine I'm
pro-vaccine I'm anti uh lockdown on Pro
lockdown like they're focused on 2020
policies and decisions and so I said at
4 30 p.m Pacific time around that time I
said look you guys are focused on this
is great you guys are attacking each
other I couldn't ask for a better kind
of fight that's happening because you
guys are so distracted
and then I spoke
I spoke again maybe a couple times and
then I came back in for like kind of
like the last moment that I spoke which
was at like an hour and 45 minutes later
and I was like look I told you an hour
and 45 minutes ago
you should keep talking about this
because you can't get off the topic
despite the fact that many people are
saying we shouldn't talk about it
anymore in an hour and 45 minutes later
you guys are still talking about it and
this is the exact reason why when it
comes to the election you guys will be a
party that's split because you can't
come to a consensus about who you want
to be the next president because of
because of covid right
reveal right petty little American
people are not gonna buy this nonsense
and here's here's one clip of why
they're not going to buy this nonsense
um this is meatball
um when they when the covet because
that's that's the [__] main argument
they're like they're like oh well this
is all about March April and May of 2020
in the lockdowns and then they start
going in the vaccine and then they
really start getting into it so there's
two issues here there's that and then so
I just want to point this out look look
I oh I can I can I can lead them to
water and it's not to advise them right
it's not to be like you guys should stop
talking about this because if you don't
then you have no chance it's to call
them out and I know I know for a fact if
I do that they're going to continue
doing the thing that I said because they
have coveted brain right I'm telling you
it's just like they have genitalia it
doesn't matter I I could have I could
give them the the wisest advice that
there is in terms of how to run the
political campaigns of what talking
points actually matter and what
Americans care about
but it doesn't matter
just because I say that doesn't mean
they're 100 not going to take my advice
and I could tell them straight to their
face and I told them at one point and
then nearly two hours later I was like
look I told you two hours ago you guys
are still bitching about the same [__]
and this is where I said it and you keep
talking about it well and the reason why
they keep talking about this is because
they they can't talk about anything else
right and it's because they've created
an entire personality an entire
ecosphere an entire ecosystem of
anti-fouchy anti-covered and it it
hasn't left them yet they haven't
decided oh that shit's over let's move
on I mean Jesus Christ even Jimmy Dore
is still doing like from front to back
on his show is about coven and lockdowns
and vaccines the American people by the
time we get to 2024 yeah the American
people like what the [__] are you covid
was three years ago you dumbasses we got
the vaccine I mean we're good to go what
are you talking about there's no
lockdowns what the [__] are you doing
they're gonna they're gonna keep talking
about it and like I said I was like keep
doing it yes and here's what here's what
I want to tell everyone you should be a
wedge in this fight you should wedge
between them and if you get in the
comments somewhere in the reply
somewhere and it's like someone Pro de
Santa show them this video watch this
video from Truman to Reagan
um and he's an American hero he's 100
years old and he's got the opportunity
now to get the vaccine so we're excited
oh yeah wait a second wait Rhonda Santos
was for the fauci ouchie is that what
yeah he got it 100 and Andy gave it to a
100 year old veteran in front of the
entire world with mask on are you not
only that not only that but that hundred
year old veteran was the one millionth
vaccine shot in the State of Florida no
[__] you know what's funny about this is
that there's nothing controversial about
this clip nothing absolutely nothing
it's exactly what governor Ron DeSantis
should have done on but they believe
it's the reason why you shouldn't vote
for him right and that's what you should
use that's what you should politicize
that's the narrative that you should
drive the wedge between these dumb
[__] because they still they
still have fouchy brain they still have
coveted brain they still have vaccine
brain where they can't think about
anything else but that because they're
[__] delusional it's crazy but that's
just the way it is so use that video I'm
gonna retweet it uh now so you got it
there uh I couldn't find the I have the
video downloaded and we're gonna play
right now this is Trump
back and forth okay uh to Ron DeSantis
so and keep in mind that this is you
know while he was president he's the one
giving Praise of Ron DeSantis for the
way that he has handled at that time
covid okay let's play it
it's loading hold on
okay all right and go Governor like Ron
DeSantis of Florida is doing a great job
we're in a play school in Florida and we
have a great Governor a great governor
knows exactly what he's doing terrific
job he just announced that the schools
will be open in the fall governor of
Florida Ron DeSantis who's done a
spectacular job in Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis is doing a fantastic job enjoys
very high popularity and that's for a
reason the reason is he's doing a good
job Governor's done a great job Florida
is
low now in the China virus he's done a
lot of things right and you're open
close and you're it's just amazing a lot
of people agree with what he's done Ron
DeSantis of Florida the governor doing a
fantastic job in Florida you're Governor
Ron DeSantis who's turned out to be just
incredible and the coronavirus you see
is going down rapidly proportionately
relatively when you look at your nursing
home situation it's a tribute to your
governor and government the job they've
done you've done a really great job and
you have a very big nursing home
population you've done a fantastic job
well I have a lot of confidence in Ron
DeSantis a lot of faith in Ron DeSantis
to make the right decision he's been
doing a great job in working very hard
he's a great Governor he's done an
incredible job and he's doing a great
job as governor
Rhonda Sanchez great governor of Florida
it's been a fantastic governor for
Florida they're very happy with them
Ron's doing a great job one of the
greatest governors in our country and I
know a lot of good ones and I can tell
you there's some really bad ones too but
this is a great one Governor Ron
DeSantis
oh man so so there's two videos a little
more proof do you need you know right
well the Rhonda Santos video that I
showed you in this one of trump when
when they're when they're pro-trump you
show them the Trump video when they're
Pro DeSantis you show them the santis
video and I'm telling you it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter that you don't
give a [__] about either of these
[__] the the purpose of
politicizing this is to drive the
message to make sure that these people
fight this out because what what here's
what I see happening Gabe Sanchez is
exactly what I've been saying is that
Rhonda Santos his campaign was over the
minute he announced on Twitter and the
minute he really decided that Elon was
going to deliver him this huge base that
was going to carry him past the Maga
cult which is [__] ridiculous but
here's the thing is that we have to in
this country we have to expose Donald
Trump because Let Me Tell You Folks if
you think him being convicted of crimes
is going to get these people to run away
from him that is one thing that I
noticed that the Ronda Santos Camp is
not saying they're not like this guy's a
[__] criminal he's a crook they're
not saying any of that folks they're not
using they're not using it against him
hardly at all so this is something that
was brought up in this the Twitter space
last night is they were like oh you know
why
and I was like yeah I agree with this
person who's pro-desantis right now in
the in the sense that all Maga people
like Trump supporters are [__]
visceral terrible people who who do
outrageous in in Vile things they're
very aggressive they're very savage-like
and I was like I actually agree with
this guy Chris like I don't agree with
the other [__] he says but I will one of
them kind of is being nice and it's
funny because like I [__] I was telling
you I was like I [__] on both sides
they're like Gabe doesn't they said uh
they're like Gabe doesn't like Ron
DeSantis or Donald Trump yeah because
you don't like fascists yeah I was like
I'm gonna call these people out for what
they are and what they've done [__] and
as a result I had [__] now I have a
bunch of [__] Pro DeSantis people and
a bunch of [__] pro-trump people
it's it's crazy because
the thing that was brought up was like
oh does Ron DeSantis even stand a chance
against Donald Trump because Donald
Trump continues to attack right he
attacks against personality he attacks
against appearance whatever Ron DeSantis
definitely has those traits as well but
Ron DeSantis his personality other than
being [__] boring in an Android is
he's trying to play this like nice guy
persona right the guy who doesn't go and
attack them he doesn't do this and as a
result he's gonna probably let Donald
Trump continue to attack right uh Ron
DeSantis he's gonna let him do it just
like he let him attack him for months he
let him call him a pedophile did all
this [__] [__] didn't say a word and
and leading up you had putting fingers
you had this you had that all of this
stuff is is just more ammunition against
Ron DeSantis and Rhonda santis doesn't
do anything he doesn't speak up doesn't
say hey hey that's that's defamation
what you're talking about there that's
this that's that doesn't say a thing he
just lets it [__] hit him and he like
turns the other cheek right and as as a
result you're gonna see more of that and
I would guarantee that Ron DeSantis
doesn't get dirty his campaign at least
His official campaign won't get dirty
but the other people maybe that are
supporters might but Ron DeSantis his
Persona is he's like a straight shooter
nice kind of guy which is different than
Donald Trump which is Donald Trump is
the I'm gonna do I'm gonna attack every
family member you have nothing's off the
table I won't feel sorry about it I
don't have any regrets I'm gonna say
what it is and I'm gonna [__] destroy
you and and those
areas
here's here's where the important where
the rubber meets the road yeah in this
fight what we have to do because Donald
Trump is going to be the nominee here
not Ronda Santos and even if Rhonda
Santa somehow has a chance we want them
to damage each other in the discourse as
much as possible and the reason why is
because we have to really break up their
vote we gotta break up their but we
gotta get people to lose confidence in
either Rhonda santis or Donald Trump and
by that I mean the people on the right
and really it's just the average
Americans who really don't pay attention
to this [__] on day to day I'm not
talking about the cult members I'm not
talking about Maga or Geck I'm talking
about people that are voting Republican
based on affiliation like I've talked
before
but they're out of the that ecosystem
but we have to we have to show through
this fight of how ridiculous Donald
Trump is and how ridiculous Rhonda
santis is and how unserious it would be
to make them the president of the United
States now it's it's a difficult task
it's a lot of work but it's very easy
when you have them fighting each other
because one thing I didn't notice last
night when I was in this room because I
wasn't there the whole time but I was
there for a significant amount and we're
going to get to some of the gifts that
they had because we got one as Alpha
cook here yeah um but um here's the
thing one thing I did notice in the room
one name they didn't mention hardly at
all was Joe Biden not [__] one and I
can't even believe that these people
have lost sight of the hunter Biden
thing like they're not even well they
did they did briefly bring up the names
they talked about Hunter Biden when so
Matt Gates came in at one point he came
in twice during the space But at the
second time he came in he was talking
about oh the weaponization of the doj
and the FBI and of course because he
doesn't want to be criminally invested
and they they asked me during the space
like okay well what about Joe Biden's
age like we've seen his his mental
capacity like deteriorate and I'm like
dude you guys are the same people that
say he's sleepy Joe Biden in a basement
and people are doing the work for him
and then you're the same people that
you're that that are coming at him and
saying like oh uh Joe Biden is actually
the Mastermind that's pulling the
strings from this Global kind of
conspiracy right China and and then and
then oh yeah Tom Fenton goes well it can
be both and I'm like no you can't you
can't have both oh that just like that's
just like my shirt fits but it doesn't
it could be both and I was like and then
when I called out Tom fit I was like Tom
fit and I was like I can't take you
seriously I mean for the whole you know
existence but I was like this is I was
like Tom Finn the same guy who emailed
uh Dan cavino to say that they won the
election and then before the election
before it was October 31st and people
were like oh what did you did the
personal attack and I was like I'm
pointing out that he's irrelevant
personal attack you did that what do you
want from me I didn't [__] I have you
wait have you you email Joe Biden no I
I've never emailed Joe Biden but I've
never emailed I've never emailed Joe
Biden to say um for the next election
you should just automatically right
declare you're the winner right I but he
did so how is that a personal that you
did that [__] what do you want from him
he was like read the whole letter and I
was like I don't have the whole letter
in front of me but I don't also need it
because I know that you do this and then
you're saying you did it even man a
personal attack what the [__] are you
talking about guys keep saying oh Donald
Trump's the victim and he was uh he you
know he didn't have a chance in the
election this and that I was like stop
[__] bitching that election was in
2020. well that's you know but I was
like you know what [__] it keep talking
about it right that's right that's the
other thing too is not only do they have
coveted brain and faucy brain they've
got [__] election fraud brain they
live in the past right and and they I'm
telling you if we if we absolutely draw
these wedges and we keep them in the
year 2020. their entire race their
entire primary race is in 2020 me when
Donald Trump finally does get the
nomination he will not be able he will
not be able to tell the American people
what he is going to do for them when he
becomes president that is the key here
is that Joe Biden is going to go not
only am I going to do this this and this
but look what I did I did this this and
this and the American people are going
to go you know what he gets up he puts
his [__] shoes on and he's not a
lunatic and he's not charged to be
federal and state crimes right so I'll
give you a little uh per like a personal
little anecdote here yeah I was at a
show and uh there's a
family member of of someone I know and
we're having a conversation and he's a
big Trumper right he had like a he has a
trump hat that has like a little it's
like a metal kind of placard on there
right he didn't have it I thought you
meant like a real metal tinfoil hat
it's like a trumpet that's right you're
saying like a metal okay okay so
that's awesome by the way yes they have
those so he had this he had this handle
that said like Trump you know make
America great again right but he didn't
have it the night that we went out
um at this venue
so we're talking and he's saying it's
like oh yeah like I got a job and I work
as an engineer at this uh this chip
factory or not a chip company wait a
second yeah yeah this ship company so I
said so I was like I know he's a big
Trumper and he's a republican all that
stuff and I was like I was like oh man I
was like small business I was like you
guys are probably gonna get a ton of new
business with the chips act and he was
like what'd you say and I was like oh
the chip sack that that Biden passed
earlier or last year I was like that's
probably gonna be pretty good for you
guys right and he was like oh yeah dude
made in America and I was like it's
about time that we've had some
competition America's first
oh my God
semiconductors and chips producing them
in America and he's like yeah man it's
gonna be awesome he didn't see it coming
either did he no no and I was like look
if you talk about these issues that's
right little not like always so [__]
George Soros [__] all the Socialists
if you talk about the actual policies
the bills that were passed and you speak
to them directly with the people that
actually it helps right right like he
like he has direct impact into his job
into his business that he works for I'm
like hey man it's pretty good right like
chips made in America being able to
compete against places like China and
Shenzhen and all this stuff and he goes
oh it's gonna be awesome man like that
chips ax is [__] awesome it's great
and I'm like guess who passed that some
[__]
but it was Democrats right guess who
opposed it guess who opposed it right
can you guess boom Republicans so it's
like it's one of those things where you
like to get people to not I'm not saying
like agree and come over to the other
side but just to like be like hey you
remember that one small thing instead be
like oh look at all these things at once
slowly build them up and have that
conversation right especially if you can
relate to them on a level that they know
about and that's and that's a great
point about slowly building them up and
that's the reason why we have to know
what election we're in we're in the
Republican primary cycle folks and that
is why we have to we have to let them
bang each other up I've gotta I've got
another
um before we move on here because we got
Donald Trump jump on but his spawn
actually I was very tempted I was very
tempted it was a last minute thing I was
like I can't no I've already decided oh
well I'm gonna play the video anyways on
here Donald Trump Jr decides to go after
DeSantis and it is [__] hilarious
that he goes after DeSantis I I still
don't know why does he call his podcast
triggered is it because of the book man
why nobody it's because of the triggered
yeah I know I know it's like oh we like
to trigger the lips yeah but your
podcast is called triggered you're
because you're he thinks that he's
triggering people he's like if you watch
this you'll get triggered
no I'm actually just laughing at you you
[__] fool I mean if you mean trigger
laughter yeah sure I mean I guess
because this is hilarious this is 17
seconds he's gonna describe to you
Rhonda Santas listen and his voice
listen to this policy grounds or
personality Trump has the Charisma of a
mortician and the energy that makes Jeb
Bush look like an Olympian
the policies of a DC swamp rat because
we've seen we've seen the flip-flops
right you can wait this is not the clip
I was thinking about but oh that was a
clip I thought that was the one where he
said Trump has the enter the Charisma of
a mortician well I mean he did say that
right he does oh I know what you're
gonna talk you're gonna you're gonna
talk about the high-pitched voice one
yeah yeah but that was I didn't even
know that one existed oh yeah I thought
that was the whole thing I thought you
were gonna talk about how the fact that
wow Donald Trump go ahead you could talk
about it I haven't even seen that one
yet okay all right so In that clip that
you saw oh my God Don Jr I don't know if
he just politician yeah I don't know if
he misread the teleprompter or
somebody's changed the text and they
accidentally put or they like uh did
what the [__] is he supposed to say he
was supposed to say DeSantis DeSantis
has the Charisma of a mortician but he
said he said Trump had the Charisma of a
mortician it could be that he's he's
just got his daddy on his brains I mean
too much I mean trumped Arrangement
syndrome it could be that plus the coke
you know it I don't even know right I'm
not even sure
but
when he misplaces the words like dude
you um man you couldn't even catch what
you said like you're so deep in this
like train of thought and reading off
the teleprompter that you didn't even
realize right that you're I mean like
did uh to Lisa I'm Ron Burgundy like I'm
Donald Trump Jr right like I saw this
last night and I was like oh God damn it
I I have to do what was that right just
on this but also this other clip that
you're gonna show so so what is funny
though about like the personality
because at one point when I was
listening when Matt Getz was in the room
because the question to him was hey
you've done debris debate prep for
DeSantis and Trump and Mac ants is like
Rhonda santis doesn't even have a
personality like that was his stance I'm
like
it was crazy because he's been uh he's
been [__] uh dragging DeSantis after
the announcement he was like oh you know
that was the most boring announcement
I've ever heard it was talking it was
right
right flat
boring announcement ever made it was so
shitty he even read the shitty speech
shitty like he could have at least
practiced it a few times like there was
some there was a time where Gates said
you think he's like nervous
Rhonda Santos well yeah no no I think
that's just who he is right and so there
was a moment was like God damn it I
agree with [__] Matt Gates yeah well
that that's the top part that's why I
said that's why I said that night I was
like I've never been on the Trump train
but choo choo [__] well last
night he made it yeah he he was like I
don't know if anyone listened to the
very end if you like happened to like
stay all the way through but Ron
DeSantis says oh this was fun we should
do it again and then yeah
goes I don't know anyone who was
listening that was like oh yeah we
should definitely do this again amen
oh so here's here's Donald Trump Jr
um talking about Rhonda Santos's voice
right this is this group he's talking
about Ronda Santos but notice what he
says about it and see if he practices
is this what he looks like right after
he does a line off the table he's like
you know Kimberly's like she's like
junior junior what's going on what's
going on he's like
you know like
well let's listen to what he says about
high-pitched nasally voices let's let's
listen I think what I noticed most about
this whole Failure to Launch was
without the visuals because it's an
audio only program you realize just how
sort of nasally and effeminate his
voices like
are you saying Donald Trump or junior
junior buddy booger sugar Junior come on
are you saying that you didn't know that
you were gonna say the thing that you
are about Rhonda Santos this is [__]
weirdest [__] I mean the ability to
again like it's always projection it's
always projection the way that they look
at themselves in the mirror and they're
practicing saying this thing
about this other person when when in
reality they're they're talking about
themselves right right
nasally and it's like dude let's not
bring noses into this okay we know that
yours is abused for sure
oh poor guy poor guy okay guy [__] that
guy huh no I mean [__] that guy hey I
listen this is the thing is that over
the next year it's gonna be very weird
you're gonna get weird feelings inside
of you with your cheering feelings when
you're cheering for Trump to destroy
DeSantis right and when you're cheering
that DeSantis gets a really good whop in
right just he's not gonna win but he
gets a real good one in like a real good
right hook you know what I mean and
you're like yeah [__] yeah get him
[__] and you're excited about Rhonda
santis I'm telling you it's gonna be
weird feelings but I I that is the
Battleground that we have to stay in and
if we don't stay in that Battleground
We're not gonna make it easy on
ourselves because we here again I want
to say this over and over and I'm going
to say it over and over the next year
and a half is that the down ballot races
are much more important than the top of
the ticket the top of the ticket is
going to drive the election it's going
to drive the narrative it should drive
the turnout but we have to have that
turnout for those down ballot races and
we have to have certain strategic points
that we have what the hell happened well
certain strategic points that we have to
have your lights your lights flip colors
it's because I didn't have it plugged in
it ran out oh man ran out of battery God
damn it just right in the middle right
in the middle of this part of the show
you should really come over to the video
part yeah see how Gabe can't keep his
lights on yeah yeah well uh go to
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez to keep
Gabe's lights on yeah please keep my
lights on help me with my computer keep
my lights on oh man so anyways
uh over the next year and a half you're
going to be in this situation where we
have to make sure we have to make sure
that we mock these people and that these
people are really questioning who
they're supporting and what faction
they're supporting is it Maga or is it
gak is it manga or is it good
why do they both sound like you're
barfing one is but when you put them
together then like I said yesterday
it just it's it's [__] Muppets man
you know it's they're [__] weird
speaking of weirdos I'm gonna go let's
go to
um the dishonorable mention first
because this is kind of an outlier in
this uh this whole narrative today that
we have
um
but we couldn't we couldn't go without
mentioning that the Texas Attorney
General Ken Paxton is in a world of hurt
and the craziest part is that he is
having literal dumpster fires yeah real
actual dumpster fires outside his office
in Texas I haven't been following you
sorry people are asking what gak is it's
great American comeback yeah that's
Rhonda Santos that's Rhonda yeah you
know I was just I was just saying so
yeah GAC Great American comeback
um and yeah make America great again so
it's Maga
you got the they got the best best
[__] taglines you guys do they do
amazing it's anyway sorry back to the
Aging talking about tag lines
[Music]
okay so the Texas Journey attorney
general Ken Paxton has been under
federal investigation for quite some
time it looks like he's going to be
impeached has that has that moved
forward at all
um he's a corrupt [__] basically
I mean there's a big question of like if
everyone knew about these crimes why did
it just take until yesterday to happen
uh because they're Republicans I don't
know if you know this oh yeah well the
question is like what like what was the
breaking point you know well the
breaking point is when someone [__]
said in a hearing that this guy and and
and
um there's a video of it somewhere if we
can find it I'm looking for the dumpster
fire video but in this hearing someone
says hey Ken Paxton says we don't want
the feds we're not going to help them
investigate and we're actually going to
impede their investigation because I
don't want them investigating this [__]
and like whoa whoa whoa what way is it
are you telling me the top law
enforcement officer
in the state said don't investigate
crimes because he doesn't want that
crime in that particular crime
investigated here's here's the clip of
that I've got it here
um this is um
um this is uh articles this is where
they were passing articles impeachment
through committee but I believe this is
is that the point I just want to make
sure I get this yeah that's the one
where they voted on it right this is the
vote
um I'm looking for the one where the the
Revelation that I'm talking about where
they're like whoa whoa whoa wait a
second are you telling me that the top
law enforcement official
um in the state said don't don't help
the feds investigate this crime
um I'm trying to find that one let's see
go to videos this [__] thing oh wait
hold on hold on did you get it yeah okay
you check your text
is that the one no no that's that's a
dumpster well that that'll work that'll
work that'll work for now uh see if you
can find that I don't know why I'm sure
because after after
this was announced
um that that and it was voted through
committee that he's going to be
impeached there was a dumpster fire
literally a dumpster fire outside his
office now this is a close-up video of
the dumpster fire there's several videos
and the fire department had to be called
to put this dumpster fire around but it
looked like in it in this video it looks
like it too a bunch of documents have
been dumped in this dumpster and set on
fire weird man I don't know why that
would be the case
or something you look down in there and
see there's a bunch of paper being
burned in the dumpster fire oh was it so
there's a lot of well there's there's uh
because like what started this I guess
is there was the
the the drunk house Speaker Dade Phelan
right
so Ken Paxton called him obviously drunk
and then from what I understand is
feeling the one that introduced The
Articles of impeachment
well again I'm not steeped in the in the
Texas politics and I hope on Tuesday
that we can get more insight um from
Texas Paul because I'm sure he's
following this a bit more on what
actually is going on there
um but that the the thing that I take
from it is Ken Paxton is a corrupt piece
of [__] and how he's how he's been
allowed to be the uh the Attorney
General of Texas not only in
re-elections but also the Republicans
not impeaching getting rid of this son
of a [__] uh is beyond me but you know
what they love their criminals that's
what I was saying earlier about how even
the DeSantis people aren't even [__]
the DeSantis people aren't even
attacking Trump on his convictions like
they're not yelling and screaming
through times they're like oh Trump
loved fauci and he shut down the country
and Ron DeSantis didn't right what he's
charged with 34 felonies you dummies his
business has convicted on 17 [__]
fraud felonies his CFO is at Rikers and
is going to turn on him possibly in this
[__] current case he's about to be
federally indicted and indicted in
Georgia on felonies why aren't you
talking about this oh yeah
because you you can't talk about that
because you believe that he's being
harangued and you went on and on and on
for months defending him that this is
all political so you can't make those
arguments now because you you won't
allow yourself to [__] know the truth
and it's beautiful I know that sounds
like it's crazy but folks
if Ronda Santos and team Rhonda santis
never never comes at Trump about his
convictions and his crimes I'm telling
you Democrats are going to in 2024.
they're gonna lay into Donald Trump like
crazy that's why they want Donald Trump
to be the nominee and I'm saying it out
loud Democrats liberals leftists should
want Donald Trump to be the nominee
because it is not going to go well for
them it's just not and the other thing
too is if Donald Trump wins the
nomination for the Republican
um National Committee
right he will destroy Ron DeSantis that
means Ronda Santos's political career is
destroyed absolutely destroyed did you
find that video of the uh of the human
yeah
no I can't find that I keep finding
videos of well of of years passed
obviously but right stuff is like this
is the so-called Republican Texas
speaker of the house he can't speak
through his drunken stupor but somehow
he can attack A.G Paxton so like I'm
also hearing this it was a general
investigating committee but it's but the
thing is who I want to know who the
articles of impeachment were were
brought up by there's a committee
obviously that votes on it
and brings it forward but who was in the
committee that brought it to their
attention well it's the general
investigative uh committee is the one
and it's chaired um here by uh Andrew
Murr right so my question is is feeling
a part of that committee is feeling the
one that's in like recommending this
behind the scenes right because people
are trying to make the and I don't know
if they're connected at all but but
people are implying is that Paxton
attacks feeling and then feeling comes
after Paxton whether directly or
indirectly right well I don't know
Republicans have a history of being
drunk on the house floor in Texas
anyways but here here's a little bit
from the committee where they were
recommending uh impeachment articles of
impeachment for attorney general Ken
Paxton Mr Johnson yes representative
Garen yes represent Longoria aye
representative
there being five eyes zero Nays zero
present not voting the motion prevails
so that's that the committee voting uh
to send articles of impeachment uh to to
the and I've got a more recent video
yeah uh hold on I still want that
[__] video I don't know which I don't
know if I've ever seen that video
you mean the one where they were
um they they say what what huh who I I
don't think I've seen that video okay
let me see if I can find um
I watched it the other day did I retweet
it [__] I don't know I try to read see
that's if you guys want a big secret out
there in the audience of what we're
gonna talk about just go to my just go
to my timeline if you want the class
syllabus right uh just go to my timeline
you'll see uh anything I retweeted is
[__] we're gonna talk about or [__] we
have talked about
um or [__] I want to talk about if we
make it to it now sometimes we get
sidetracked and we have to watch other
things
um but we're and we're gonna get to uh
there was basically the clip and I can't
find it now but the clip was uh oh hold
on is this it
now that's that's not the clip I'm
looking for no so this is in preparation
they're now passing out copies but then
there's an actual there's another clip
that I saw that's them actually handing
out the copies on the on the house floor
right right when when are they supposed
to vote for the Articles impeachment I'm
assuming soon well one hour uh um hold
on let me see you on this other video
the other video that I saw was about
from an hour ago so I don't know maybe I
would assume sometime today right
um the the good news is that it seems
that Ken Paxton that corrupt
[__] is not going to be the
Attorney General of Texas anymore now
whether he actually ends up in prison
for the crimes that he's committed and
the corruption that he's done right um
you know that'll be another story and
that'll be a whole nother it looks like
the person to follow on this is a Sergio
Martinez Beltran okay do you have his
Twitter account maybe that video yeah
here's the well here's the video we'll
start with this here's the video of them
walking down and putting on everyone's
desk
the actual article the actual the 20
articles of impeachment 20 Jesus it says
Texas house panel adopted 20 articles
impeachment against so I just want to
know like what is like what is in it
proposed articles of impeachment
alleging Brave offenses justifying the
committee the committee's unanimous
recommendation
as you know the committee met on
Wednesday to hear a presentation of
evidence by the committee's lawyers
oh I got it
[Music]
sergeants are also passing out
so there it is there's the so go to the
next link that I sent you is this the uh
this is the 20 articles okay
um so this is the 20 articles of
impeachment that that uh they're passing
out is what you're saying okay so here
we got
um here is seven counts of disregard of
uh official Duty two counts of
misapplication of public resources two
counts the Constitutional bribery Jesus
Christ two counts of obstruction Justice
sounds like sounds like a goddamn
Republican three counts of false
statements in a push of Records also
Republican one count of conspiracy to
attempted or attempted conspiracy yeah
Republican one count of dare election
and Duty yeah certainly Republican one
count of unfitness for office that has
to be Republican one count of abuse and
public trust nothing other than
Republicans so there's your 20 articles
of impeachment
um that uh attorney Republican attorney
general and crook [__] right Ken
Paxton from the state of Texas so I I
want to move on because we're going to
we're going to write I mean I'm assuming
it'll go the way that we think it will
which is like if it went unanimous on
the committee it'll probably go a
majority in in the vote
which would be [__] crazy because
it's like eight years this guy's been
you know under investigation by the FBI
right right and it's like he's under
Federal indictment right yeah yeah and
it's like what what do you need to do to
get this guy out well like okay now he's
soon enough I would imagine by today
he'll be a private citizen it it feels
like that the Republicans are moving on
him like a [__] because he's now an
he's now an anchor he's no longer an
asset to them right and and I'm telling
you folks I know it doesn't feel like it
but Trump's they're gonna do the same
thing with Trump they're gonna hold this
[__] criminal up on high keep him in
keep him in power as long as they
possibly can because he's a [__] [__]
box and he he gets [__] boxes to follow
them he gets [__] boxes to be loud for
them and then at the end of the day when
it doesn't serve their interest anymore
they're gonna chop him off like a
[__] wart on your on your they're
gonna yeah they they will keep anyone in
their party so long as they
benefit right whether it's through they
add to the Grift or they're able to push
further the policies
that uh you know the fascist policies
that the Republican party wants and as
soon as you're too like you've got too
much weight too much baggage they'll cut
you off but at that point you've got
your it says okay doj asks Travis County
to hold up on the investigation doj is
currently investigating him yeah man
it's like the guy it is one of those
things where it's like you you know
seven eight years you've got this point
of of being like man what is it going to
take what is it gonna take well and not
only what is it going to take is what
they're actually gonna charge him with
and he's gonna get in a trial for it now
let's move on to our Alpha cuck she was
in the Twitter space as well last night
and I wanted to get in she was at the
very end I actually requested a
microphone because I listened to this
[__] sludge talk about how Dem Mario
posed a question he's like not not to
get into politics but why why in this
country in America is is it's so divide
and so visceral and why why does it seem
like the country's divided and she goes
to divide the countries he says
Democrats want to abort babies even
after birth I'm like you lying sack of
[__] [__] and you know I'm talking
about the dumbest person in Congress
well
possibly running for position of the
dumbest person in Congress
representative Lauren bobert the clown
oh my god
um but there is more news there is more
news than just this Twitter space that
she was in last night and this is what I
wanted to ask her about last night yeah
well I wanted to get in and ask her too
there's a 9-1-1 call
um that has been Unearthed here now when
what is this call when are they so this
was this is from last year okay so this
is last year now who who is making the
911 call it's her son correct her son
yeah okay
um and her son is calling 9-1-1 on who
on Jason bobert that's Jason with a Y
the husband oh well yeah now I mean who
who would have thought right who would
have thought that the guy who uh whipped
out his dick in front of underage girls
at a bowling alley and has reportedly uh
he drove over the neighbor's mailbox and
then was aggressive and threatened to
release their dog or whatever it was uh
physical harm against the person that
was serving him the papers for their
divorce right and each point these
things happened
Lauren bobert is there to protect Jason
no no no Jason doesn't even drink Bud
Light no one even mentioned [__] Bud
Light they said he was there drinking a
beer and he was he was visibly upset and
said he still loved her that's funny and
then
Lauren bobert being like no he didn't do
this when there's a 9-1-1 call from the
time that the neighbor called about the
mailbox right and they're making noises
and they're doing the [__] go-kart
[__] or their ATV up and down
four-wheeler up and down the street and
drove over the mailbox all that [__]
right 9-1-1 call there's this 9-1-1 call
which is Lauren bobert once again
protecting Jason bobert for child abuse
physically abusing their child right
because the the son talks about it in
the 9-1-1 call
um and a local TV station here ran this
first the ABC 13 KRDO I think it is
um here's here's the uh here's the audio
of that 9-1-1 call that KRDO released he
just like thought because
yeah I don't know why he got that and he
just started yelling at me and he
started throwing me
Jason bobert
okay so so he says he's throwing him I
don't know exactly what that means but
it sounds pretty violent uh he doesn't
know why again total surprise Republican
man
Super Macho right has a history of doing
things that are inappropriate and
abusive
right well man let's let's listen to
what she does uh when she gets on the
call because she actually gets on the
call here let's listen
all I wanted to say all I wanted to say
is me and my dad were starting to yell
but he said he didn't really get
physical with me it was just like I was
overwhelmed
me and my dad were over hi
I'm the mom
hi um
okay so there was an argument over
dinner I understand you guys got to come
and talk to them I'm down at our second
location with I was already here getting
things ready for an event
but
I don't know I was talking to him and he
said that he had called so
just let you know I have him his dad's
up at the house
yeah he had told me he was going to be
down at The Farmhouse and I've got him
headed that way to help him
yeah he doesn't need help but they can
they can come here yeah
so there's the there's the audio that is
never going to go away for Lauren bobert
and Jason bobert Jason with the wiring
by the way
um which may be all you need to know
um
again at the at the start of the tape
you hear the the boy her son
um very scared her dad's getting
physical and then when Lauren bobert
enters the conversation off the phone
um the child starts to change the the
tune oh he didn't really get physical I
just got overwhelmed so I called you and
then she gets on the phone she's like oh
don't don't worry it's no big deal dad's
at the house you can come and talk to
him but everything's fine everything's
fine it really seems like there and it
looks like so from what I was gathering
too it looks like I'm just well I'm
trying to verify that it's the oldest
son which is the one that's about to
have a child uh who's who's 17 just
turned 18
um but what I was reading is that it
looks like the
bobert's son said the congresswoman was
living at the family's Farmhouse due to
family problems
or whatever in that phone call right
that would uh
according according to what I'm picking
up here is it was she is at the other
like she lives at The Farmhouse or
whatever like right they've got they've
had so they were having marital problems
last year right
um did she I wonder who the the name is
that they they blanked at do you think
that's the person
um what's his name the guy the uh the
ramen Shaman do you think that's the I
don't know oh I don't know that's a good
question it was redacted I'm just making
assumptions here I wonder if it was
because University theories are to get a
cease and desist letter at all I'm not
trying to do that at all no not at all I
mean I I have no idea I mean like how am
I supposed to know it's redacted I'm
just making guesses here yes if you're
saying that she's lived at The Farmhouse
the second location and possibly because
their marriage has been on the racks for
a while right maybe the redacted person
is the person who she's at The Farmhouse
with and maybe that person right the his
name rhymes with Ramen Shaman I'm just I
mean if I were to guess that's a
possibility because from again from what
I've read so far about this 911 call it
says after after her son hung up the
phone he went to the um he went to The
Farmhouse where bober was so Lauren
bober was staining it's it's from what I
understand second location second
location is The Farmhouse and she was
staying there she was not staying at the
main house bobert was staying at the
farmhouse on the property of the main
house where Jason was so they were
already split up it sounds like for
family marital problems right
something's going on so he he hung up
the phone went to go get her his mom
Lauren bobert she got on the phone and
then when the operator called back he
recanted the story and said all I wanted
to say it was in me and my dad started
yelling and he got physical with me and
he's like hi I'm the mom and then what
we heard is what we heard right right
and so
it said he overreacted Jason told
Insider every teenage boy is going to
want to test the bull we've gotten over
it
I don't think it's really testing the
bull as much as it's a it's a father
abusing physically abusing their kid and
say what you will about the family and
how [__] up Lauren bobert and Jason
bobert is right
but those children have unfortunately
been raised in a house where
[__] reality isn't what it is right
right and and being told that oh if I
physically abuse you it's because you
did something wrong you deserved it not
because I as the parent Jason bobert am
abusive and I got my own [__] to deal
with and I'm gonna take it out on a
weaker person because that's what a
[__] tough man does well that's the
problem what's going on there he is in
the [__] box he's but they're being
spelled with a wine man and yeah no not
only not only not only is he spelled
with a wise a [__] sleazeball scumbag
but they're both terrible people and the
reason especially around this is if I
was a parent and I had a child
and and my partner physically abused my
child
I'd be like [__] no
and go after the the parent but I
understand that relationships are
different in the way and how they're all
complex
but the way that Lauren bober protects
Jason bobert and I can guarantee this is
not the first time this has been done
right there have probably been other
moments where Jason has been physically
abusive whether to Lauren bobert or to
uh to to her son right or Sons well and
and you know
um but she protects she's protects well
I I asked you yesterday is maybe this
has something to do with the divorce
with this coming out not with the event
but this event starting to come to the
Forefront maybe it's just untenable
anymore for her to be married to such a
pile of [__] which right wow it's
amazing that she's such a pile of [__]
and she couldn't stand to be married to
a biology but that's how it works
speaking of piles of [__] [__] let's
go to our uh winner of the week our
bonehead of the week Ron DeSantis
there's all kinds of reasons to put this
guy on the bone of the week I want to
show you a couple of them but one of
them is his failed launch his Failure to
launch a boy presidential campaign it's
crazy that's I think that's why the
audience probably voted for him to be
bone of the week why I trust Elon Musk
to do this at all but more than that why
would you try to Gaslight people I'm
going to show you something I I've been
keeping track of there's this Twitter
account called Rhonda santis War Room
have you seen this they keep they keep
tweeting about how many views now this
was this was a couple days ago right it
says 9 million views right on this
Rhonda Santos video you see that Rhonda
Santos post this video about I'm running
for president to lead our Great American
comeback gack
um and the Ronda Santa's War Room says
nine million views okay you got it are
you following so far okay so I said
no not nine million you [__]
boneheads I said gak doesn't know how to
count it's giganomics instead of
meganomics yeah because they said it's 9
million and at that point it was
4.7 million right
if I were to imagine right the number
that they're reading right it says 9
million
views on the Tweet right nine million
views on the video and what the reading
is this is Elon Musk
rebranding yeah yeah he he rebranded
Impressions to views so when people see
it they look oh man look at all those
views that's any person that [__]
encounters that tweet they don't see it
they scroll back it's an impression
which means if there's if there's nine
million views but there's only actually
4.7 million views half the people like
[__] this [__] right half the people
that no no no thank you I don't even
want to watch it so on top of that to
give you to explain to the audience what
Elon Musk is trying to do he's now
trying to inflate the metrics that
people see on the public side
so when you see the videos now you no
longer see the video view count if you
notice that the view count is uh has
been removed at least if the updated
version of the app and also on the
desktop
the The View counter gone the Tweet view
count is still there right well I have
not updated my Twitter app so I can
actually see it that's why I posted if
you go to if you go to tweets on on the
desktop right now you'll notice that
yeah it doesn't have it it does not have
the original view count tweet which
means that you have an inflated number
and by this example you've got something
that was double the amount of
Impressions but half the amount of
actual views right of people actually
viewing it this is this is this is
someone freedom of speech this is what
you see when uh like uh especially when
you're like hey I got this company and
somebody's like hey I'm interested in
your company let me see the numbers and
you're like totally and maybe you fudge
the numbers or maybe you look like daily
active users are more like are
increasing or maybe you see like oh look
engagement for posting videos and
watching videos are up
this is something you do when you're
trying to make something
more attractive to an outside party to
come in and take over and purchase well
that's it seems a little weird that you
would want to inflate the value of
something that you you think is totally
fine why are you trying to right
well also in Ron DeSantis bonehead world
I want to show you some actual substance
okay uh Ron desantis's bone-headed and I
actually hope that Trump picks up on
this and Liz Harrington if you're
listening if you're listening out there
this would be in a great tagline for
Trump he should do a couple crazy ass
hostage videos you know the ones that we
make fun of every once in a while that
we helped you you know get get situated
to where they were decent at least like
visually not yeah yeah not scripted
Jesus Christ keep going with the fashion
stuff that's fantastic but here's the
key fashion yeah flashy vashy but if you
if you if you want to actually get to
some substance of how Rhonda santis uh
will destroy America this is [__]
fantastic listen to this report listen
well this is a couple reports this is a
a montage of them listen to what is
happening in Florida because Rhonda
Santos is a [__] fascist idiot but
for many business owners the law has
left a bitter taste you have to have
have a plan set up for that to take
place it's no different than the bills
health care bill and stuff like that
nothing can be replaced unless you
really have a long setup process for the
next thing to take hold you can't just
say hey I'm going to get rid of these
people and then look at the farmers that
are left without workers aware of the
need for agricultural workers Jerry
Spencer turned to unemployed Americans
but says after two weeks most couldn't
cope with the American workers they all
had to be taught all this and separate
and and in addition to the fact that
their bodies just were not
built for it so it almost sounds like
they're too fat is that what you took he
was trying to be nice yeah I don't know
okay so this is going to continue on but
I want to give the audience an idea um
this is a law that they passed in
Florida that they were excited about
that would basically prevent migrants
from working on farms right dumbass well
um so he's pissing off the farmers and
Liz Harrington if you're listening
listen if you're listening Liz this is a
great attack line because Trump claims
he's for the farmer which he's really
not he destroyed farming in America just
like Rhonda Santos is destroying in
Florida yeah people are really good at
[__] farmers and somehow oh no not
only that but you're gonna [__] people
who are actually working the fields who
I don't know aren't white so I would
love to see their break on right now
protecting these lives right these
people so so and we're going to continue
I'm gonna watch the rest of this because
this is actually substantive argument
that Trump and the Trump Camp could make
this is real [__] that they could do now
they they dance around the Disney thing
because they can't really because they
hate wokism but they can't they can't
get over the fact that Rhonda Sands is
going after private business and the
first amendment of that private business
so it's a rough one but this one should
be really [__] easy for you guys
really easy Rhonda Santos is [__]
Farmers you don't even have to bring up
that it's about migrant workers just
pretend that it's not you pretend a lot
of things you lie about a lot of [__] so
just pretend that it's not we'll
actually get the facts out there won't
call you on it when you were a support
of Migrant workers and next year in the
general election we'll say yeah you
refer Market workers when you were
against Ron DeSantis but watch the rest
of this report it's it's it's actually
it makes me feel really bad for Florida
and and Americans because it is going to
affect a little bit of food food supply
in the supply chain generation farmer
Scott Benton says the effect on farming
was devastating a lot of people left
and all the workers left and and people
were you know I already had the crops
out there ready to harvest so they
didn't have anybody to pick them so a
lot of farms lost their whole crop
you're not going to get an entitled
American to come out and do the work
that we do for over 40 years John Alger
has been in the farming industry we saw
some of the work his people do some
tractor driving some manual labor
it's hot there's mosquitoes out here
it's uh it's it's uncomfortable
situation why do you tell someone who
says I'm not a farmer I don't hire
undocumented immigrants this doesn't
affect me
good for them get ready to pay more at
the grocery store and this may not be
the only industry affected we're already
getting calls from construction workers
and those who employ them the law goes
into effect July 1st rat row they're
already preparing for this law to
destroy industries in Florida now again
I I would love to knock around DeSantis
and we did plenty of it with the Elon
part about his failed launch for his
presidential campaign but here's the
thing is that we have to know these
wedges we have to draw these wedges and
this is going to be a big one folks this
is going to be huge for the Florida
economy it is going to [__] suffer
this summer the Florida economy
absolutely relies on agriculture and
their export to other states of
Agriculture and other countries
um when when the migrant workers go to
Florida during the picking season and
and actually Harvest this food for
America and around the world not only
that when the construction stops the
economy he stops I don't know if Ron
DeSantis knows that or not but they
really they really went balls deep into
wokism and hatred and bigotry so much so
that they lost sight of what the effect
really truly would be and I'm glad I'm
glad Ron DeSantis decided to have this
battle I'm glad Ron DeSantis decided to
have this experiment in Florida where he
could show the entire country that this
is [__] bone-headed stuff it doesn't
work it's really stupid it hurts the
economy it hurts Americans it hurts
migrants it hurts it hurts the economy
with prices and you are a [__] idiot
when you're a bigot you're a dumb
[__] bigot and you don't know what
you're talking about it's the same
stupid [__] with Bud Light and Target
they don't understand what they're
talking about they don't understand what
their hatred and their bigotry that long
slippery slope of it is is going to end
up with at the end of it because they
are absolutely hell-bent
on not knowing what the truth or reality
truly is and because they're so
unfucking tethered from reality it is
our advantage to politicize it it is our
advantage to make them fight over it and
it's our advantage to make the contrast
very clear that you either want someone
who's in charge of a state a county of
or a [__] or a [__] country that
has their [__] goddamn wits about
them that isn't absolutely obsessed with
owning the libs they want what is good
for the American people as a whole
regardless of how popular unpopular it
may be or how well they implemented or
wait may not implement it the point is
is that the American people should be at
the Forefront of your policies and
Rhonda santis and Donald Trump don't
even don't even consider the American
people with their policies at all they
only consider their bigotry and their
bases bigotry and this is a prime
example of that and again Liz if you're
listening and I don't know if she still
does but if you're listening this would
be a great one for Trump
do you understand this is against the
farmers it hates the farmers
he's gonna destroy the fire I'm the
greatest president for Farmers of all
time even though I distorted trade
routes to China for Farmers that they
worked for decades and decades to build
I destroyed them in just a few years I
mean honestly there's no worse [__]
party for Farmers than [__]
Republicans and I don't understand why
farmers keep I mean you know Republicans
want to [__] complain about the fact
of like oh inflation and the price are
going up is like yeah well what happens
what happens
if you cut the [__] Source off right
what happens because you decided oh well
uh these These are an undocumented
versus documented why wouldn't you try
to create a pipeline a program
to citizenship right or to documentation
or whatever it is right
and working that way but unfortunately
you know white people uh super [__]
fragile super [__] triggered very
upset at the fact that maybe someone who
isn't white would do better than them
despite the fact that these very white
people who [__] and moan wouldn't
[__] last an hour in the same
conditions that anyone
who is Mexican or Latino or whatever
would be able to withstand actual hard
workers actual people who were like look
this is all I have
I don't have a job security I don't have
social I don't have a unemployment to
benefit off I don't have these programs
that you would as someone who was born
here right I gotta [__] work for my
[__] I gotta earn it you you were
privileged you got it I didn't wait you
mean capitalism is that what you mean
yeah because here's here I want to show
you a tweet that is just it's so [__]
it just encapsulates what we're talking
about with this wokism and and Bud Light
and Target and now oh we can't have
migrants and brown people and
immigration and they just they can't
help themselves with their hatred and
bigotry white people are not skilled and
talented and creative enough to keep
these things going right if you have a
[__] Echo chamber a silo of white
people like Matt [__] Walsh over here
it's going to be a very boring Ron
DeSantis like environment where people
just go oh hi
hello right good and there's gonna be no
there's gonna be no work being done no
labor being done because they're not
willing to do it the new the New York
Post which oh man what is a totally a
trustworthy Source wink wink especially
on their Twitter account it says
Target loses 9 billion in week following
boycott calls over LGBT friendly
clothing Matt Walsh tweets retweets this
quote tweets it and says this is awesome
keep going death metal Viking points
this out so clearly because this is [__]
folks this is weird this is [__]
weird that the right wing is excited
about about being anti-capitalist okay
there it's really weird it hasn't
happened in our country and honestly
this is actually the entry point in the
open door for all leftists to get behind
and not be not be pro-capitalism but go
hey we can actually crush them using
this and death metal Viking points this
out so clearly in this tweet he says
I've learned the true gay agenda was to
get conservatives to destroy capitalism
all on their own because that's that's
truly what they're doing here and
they're really they're really painting
themselves as the anti-anti-capitalist
anti-labor and and it's it's just gonna
compound into the economy being complete
[__] and these states where they make
these stupid bone-headed decisions
because it's not going to affect the
states as much that aren't making these
bone-headed decisions like California is
the number one in agriculture okay
and they're not making these bone-ended
decisions about migrants they're going
to be they're going to be harvesting
crops in California they're going to do
that and continue to do that they're not
gonna they're not going to in Florida
and guests guests guess where that slack
is going to be pulled up all around the
country in these states that aren't
doing the stupid [__] like Rhonda santis
where they're actually they're they're
so hyper focused on their [__]
bigotry that they can't see the forest
through the trees
and again this is one of those things
where like um
you know you heard people say when when
Newsmax was dropped from 18t and DirecTV
right they dropped them and then I was
on a message board the other day looking
to find it was like where is this 15
billion dollars coming from right
because I was looking something up uh
for a a recent uh what was that video
I'm doing on Ted Cruz
and in this form someone's like
ATT lost 15 billion dollars and people
were like where are you getting 15
billion dollars from and they're like oh
well so-and-so said it or whatever and
they're like so you don't have any
Source also I highly doubt that Newsmax
being dropped because Newsmax wanted to
be charging DirecTV and ATT to be on
there uh their their list of of channels
that was the reason they lost 15 billion
and then basically when you're looking
at it you're like there's no [__]
connection right and this is another go
to the stock market go to the stock
prices and look so now people are like
oh well they lost 9 billion okay they
lost 9 billion in value I don't know the
the exact amount but in value of the
stock price now I have a feeling that
that stock price is going to come right
back up right you whoa whoa whoa you
mean that stock prices can go down and
come back up it's crazy is that what
you're saying I will I will give Target
a little bit of [__] here yes go ahead
and the [__] that I give Target is the
same [__] that I give other corporations
who for the month of June say pride
pride pride we love we love Pride we
love the lgbtq community right and then
before that and after that it's
to get a community I actually think that
that is a legitimate
um a legitimate argument for Target but
we have to keep our outrage towards the
people who are threatening Target and
people exactly Target that's where we
need to direct our outrage and I mean
I'm not saying that you shouldn't hold
corporations accountable that's why
that's why you should but again we have
to keep our outrage in the correct
direction because folks they don't care
about Target they don't care about who
it is or what it is they want any Target
they can to to to enhance their bigotry
and to pretend as if their bigotry has
power and their white supremacy has
power and it doesn't it doesn't have
power it doesn't have to have power and
and that's why Rhonda santis is the
bonehead of the week because he can't
stop with his white supremacy his
bigotry and his fascism is destroying
the State of Florida because he's the
governor there and he's the bone the
week because you voted for him you
decided Ron weirdo meatball putting
fingers
dissanctimonious whatever [__]
nickname you have when there's a
thousand nicknames for him it's Rob now
his name is
Rob the sanctimonious meatball let's
give him his dude
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
I have to say meatball you really came
out front and you whipped on Trump's ass
in this election Point that'll be the
only election that you win against at
one point during the poll it was like 90
and it was like oh God damn oh man it's
gonna I think by the end of it uh you
know total was like 68 69 or something
like that but yeah on Twitter it was
like
all right well just enjoy it Ron enjoy
it because that might be the only
election that'll be the only election
that you win against Donald Trump for
sure and I'm sure you'll be back on the
bonehead poll with Donald Trump oh yeah
at some point and you may win that one
again too so you can look forward to
winning I could I could see many many
more head-to-head races right of Donald
Trump versus Ron DeSantis in the next
year or so I could even see Elon in at
this same poll being done oh the next
year and it it feels so weird and I know
the audience it feels so weird to be on
the Trump train when you're like oh my
God I [__] hate this but you know
what listen if I'm just here all right
I'm not for the whole destination that's
right that's right Hey listen if we can
if we can cheer on Trump to destroy Ron
DeSantis and then we can destroy Donald
Trump next year choo choo [__]
everybody this has been bone of the week
stick around we got a few announcements
right after this
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
of the week that's always a great one
great bone and I love Friday we're a
little over we we have been going over
but it's Memorial Day weekend so I'm
going to bring that up
um so I have a safe Memorial Day weekend
hopefully that you get to spend a little
time with your family and your friends
this weekend
um you can do that
um Gabe are you going to do your your
patreon stuff this week and even though
it's holiday weekend
um see I got I definitely have stuff
Saturday I don't know I'm I'm kind of
thinking maybe I won't because I imagine
people are probably traveling and stuff
I'm gonna try to do I'm gonna try to do
my Sunday rant um and so everyone on
patreon go to Gabe's patreon you go to
what was that uh show.com what was that
show.com
two or three episodes in the works one
I'm writing right now about okay Ted
Cruz good
so so keep an eye on his patreon page
for what will happen this weekend over
holiday weekend definitely keep an eye
in mind I'm gonna plan on doing my
Sunday rant I'm just not sure when it's
gonna happen
um if it's at the normal evening time or
some of the time I'm hoping that I don't
have any family events and I hope I can
spend a little time with you guys on
patreon at least for 30 minutes or so so
if you're watching the patreon page go
to patreon.com the Tony Michaels uh and
why are there visit Gabe's page as well
are you almost to 100 you're getting
close I'm I'm awesome okay so get Gabe
to 100 get them over there again go to
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez uh give us
95 right now five more he needs five
more one two three four five Margaritas
I'm wondering maybe if he gets if he
gets five more um Margaritas I wonder if
he'll do the Peggy for you I don't know
I'm just saying okay
also also don't forget to subscribe here
on YouTube you're not going to want to
miss a single episode of the Tony
Michaels podcast every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific and also on Memorial
Day itself we're gonna broadcast on
Monday we will be here if you're not
that's fine I know if you got family
stuff going on great um but if you can
come join us on Monday we might do
something special we might have a fun
time uh surely there'll be some news to
talk about but we'll be we'll be yapping
our traps on Memorial Day for two hours
at least also follow us on Twitter at
Tony Michaels pod and if you can you can
watch it over on Facebook on Memorial
Day at the Tony Michaels live every
single weekday including on Monday on
the holiday and let me tell you
something let's check in on Twitter or
twitch over here excuse me
oh man we're really close uh to 1200
followers on Twitch if you could do us a
huge favor if you don't have a Twitch
account or you do have a Twitch account
you haven't followed us over there go to
twitch.tv Tony Michaels that's twitch.tv
Michael it is free to follow us then
cost you single nickel to follow us
we're so close to 1200 over there and we
want to thank everyone who has linked
their Amazon Prime account to their
Twitch account and give us that one free
subscription you get with Amazon gaming
with your Prime account
it gives us a few dollars every month
and don't forget if you've done it
before you have to renew it every month
so go check on it if you haven't checked
on in a while you may have to renew it
so Amazon gives us that two bucks
because that's literally I think it's
two dollars and seven cents is what they
get when you do that so go over renew
that or or link your account you go to
the tonymichaels.com you can and the
instructions are have a link your Amazon
account to your Twitch account are there
and thank you to everyone who has
re-subscribed everyone who has
subscribed everyone who's given us
support on Twitch it's growing over
there more and more people are watching
us uh on Twitch more more and more
people are in the chat every single day
so we appreciate uh having our fans and
and our um our folks in the audience on
Twitch it's very good that we have the
[__] fan across social media
platforms that's the goal we want to
grow the [__] band we want to grow
the The Narrative and National messaging
as we get into this Republican primary
fight against Donald Trump and meatball
Ron DeSantis and make them fight this
out over covid
like I said yes they're in the Twitter
space I'm not gonna stop you I'm gonna
call it out yes and you're gonna keep
doing it
hey I I am all for Trump and the Santa's
camps fighting over who loves fauci the
most who who loves them the most who
loves fauci more let's ding ding ding
let's get ready to I can't say it
because it's copyright but right yeah
you know what I'm talking about in the
room yeah boy everyone have a safe
weekend
um eat some barbecue or whatever you
guys do on Memorial Day drink some beer
drink some uh Bud Light Coors Miller
whatever whatever beer makes you feel
the gayest
um drink it out there and just be safe
have fun happy Memorial day we'll see
you on Monday if you're around
same time same place Surf's Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] them [__]
them
[Music]
Murphy's mewborn headass Beacon